[MUSIC PLAYING]
EVAN JONES: Hi, there.
Evan here.
I'm a technical curriculum
developer for Google Cloud.
JENNY BROWN: And
hi from me, Jenny.
I'm a sales trainer
for Google Cloud.
EVAN JONES: On an
earlier episode,
we looked at our
Google BigQuery can
help you get meaningful
insights from your data.
The hands on labs
also gave you a chance
to use the web UI and
the command line tool
to query public tables and
load in a sample of that data
into BigQuery.
You can check out our
link to that episode here.
JENNY BROWN: On
this episode though,
we're appealing to the
basketball lovers out there.
Through a hands on
lab, you're going
to use BigQuery to explore the
NCAA data set of basketball
games, teams, and players.
The game data covers
play-by-play and box scores
back to 2009, as well as
final scores back to 1996.
But if you love your data
more than you love basketball,
that's fine too.
[SWOOSH]
JENNY BROWN: It
isn't a coincidence
that this lab is
based on NCAA data.
As part of its
journey to the Cloud,
the NCAA is migrating
over 80 years
of historical and
play-by-play data
from 90 championships
and 24 sports.
EVAN JONES: At
Google Cloud, we're
extremely proud and excited to
be the official public Cloud
provider of the NCAA.
Check out their link
to see how the NCAA is
using Google Cloud to tap
into decades of sports data.
JENNY BROWN: With $100,000
up for grabs, Google
Cloud, NCAA, and Kaggle teamed
up for a unique competition
using the NCAA March
Madness Tournament
as the common backdrop.
Participants strengthened
their knowledge
of basketball, statistics, data
modeling, and cloud technology
while competing
against each other
for the most innovative
applications of machine
learning.
Check out this link
for the blog post.
[SWOOSH]
EVAN JONES: Now, before we dive
into the world of basketball,
let's do a quick
recap of BigQuery.
JENNY BROWN: BigQuery is a
fully managed, massive scale,
low cost enterprised
data warehouse
running on top of Google's
proven compute, storage,
and networking infrastructure.
This allows you to focus less on
developing your infrastructure
and more on finding
insights from your data.
EVAN JONES: It's super fast too,
scanning terabytes in seconds,
and even petabytes in minutes.
This makes interactive
self-service exploration
of massive data
sets viable, which
means better analysis,
more creativity,
and you can derive more
interesting insights.
[SWOOSH]
JENNY BROWN: So now for
the fun bit, quick labs.
In this hands on
lab, you're going
to run a bunch of cool
queries against the NCAA
data set using BigQuery.
Some of the results
might just surprise you.
EVAN JONES: Now, you
can check out the link
to start the quick lab here.
And keep in mind it's going
to take you about 45 minutes
to complete.
Now, so far in the lab, we
found the NCAA public data set
in BigQuery.
We then preview the NCAA
men's play-by-play table.
We create a query to find the
types of basketball plays.
We run some fun
queries, including
finding which teams scored
the most points in a game.
Here we find out which 10
teams scored the most points
cumulatively since 2010.
We also wanted some
more complex queries
to determine which conferences
are the best at winning
tight games.
We hope you enjoyed this episode
and had some fun analyzing
the NCAA data set.
We'd love to hear how
Google BigQuery has
helped you gain insights
into your own data sets too.
JENNY BROWN: If you
haven't signed up
for the $300 free trial credit
on GCP, check out this link.
It's a great way to apply
what you've learned.
EVAN JONES: All of our
additional training resources
are linked below.
Thanks again for watching,
and we'll see you again soon.
SPEAKER 1: Check out our
episode on building a slack bot
using the Botkit
toolkit and running it
on Google Cloud Platform.
Watch the video and the
quick lab demo here.